¿Los políticos en un gran proyecto informático complejo y sofisticado?
Eso es un desastre en potencia.
No necesariamente.
Hay un precedente de servicios con componente tecnológica
iniciado por políticos en varios países
y que ha sido muy exitoso:
las loterías nacionales.
Analicemos el caso de Gran Bretaña.
Nuestro gobierno no diseñó la lotería nacional
no fundó la lotería nacional, ni opera la lotería nacional.
Votó la Ley de la Lotería Nacional y esto es lo que ocurrió.
Esta ley define las características de una lotería nacional.
Especifica ciertos beneficios
que sólo el Estado puede otorgar a los operadores.
E impone algunas obligaciones a esos operadores.
En materia de difusión del juego de azar entre las masas
tuvo un éxito sin parangón.
Pero supongamos que nuestro objetivo
es brindar nueva actividad económica a la base de la pirámide.
¿Podríamos usar el mismo modelo?
Creo que sí.
Imaginen que los políticos definen una estructura.
Llamémosla Mercados Electrónicos Nacionales, o MEN.
Piénsenlo como un servicio público regulado.
Está a la par del suministro de agua o la red de carreteras.
Y hay una serie de mercados bajo nivel de intercambio
que puede ser atendido por una persona o una pequeña empresa.
Y el gobierno cuenta con ciertos beneficios
que puede otorgar a estos mercados.
Es gasto público destinado a estos mercados
para comprar servicios públicos a nivel local.
Se trata de interconectar estos mercados
directamente con los más altos canales oficiales.
Se trata de consagrar el papel del gobierno como publicista de estos mercados.
Se trata de desregular algunos sectores
para que pueda ingresar la gente local.
Los viajes en taxi pueden ser un ejemplo.
Y esos beneficios deberían acarrear determinadas obligaciones
para los operadores,
siendo la clave, claro,
que los operadores paguen por todo,
incluso por la interconexión con el sector público.
Imaginen que los operadores ganen dinero
generando un porcentaje del margen en cada transacción.
Imaginen que hay un período de concesión
definido en quizá 15 años
en los que pueden quedarse con estos beneficios y operar con ellos.
Imaginen que a los consorcios que pujan para operarlos se les dice
que quien entre con el margen porcentual más bajo de cada transacción
para financiar todo
cerrará el trato.
El gobierno entonces sale de la estructura
que ahora queda en manos del consorcio.
Ellos o bien desatarán un montón de oportunidades económicas
y obtendrán un porcentaje de ganancia
o bien todo estallará en mil pedazos
y será un duro golpe para los accionistas.
Esto no necesariamente debe impactar al contribuyente.
Y no existirían restricciones mercados alternativos.
Esta sería solo otra alternativa más
entre millones de foros de Internet.
Pero podría ser muy diferente,
porque tener acceso a esas estructuras con respaldo estatal
podría incentivar a estos consorcios
a invertir seriamente en el servicio.
Porque obtendrían un montón de pequeñas transacciones
para empezar a recuperar dinero.
Estamos hablando de sectores como peluquería a domicilio,
alquiler de juguetes, trabajos agrícolas,
alquiler de ropa e incluso reparto de comida a domicilio,
servicios para turistas, atención domiciliaria.
Sería un mundo de intercambios muy pequeños, pero muy bien informados,
porque los mercados electrónicos nacionales entregarán datos.
Esta es una persona local
que analiza incursionar en el mercado del cuidado de niños.
Y podrían tener que financiar investigación de antecedentes y capacitaciones
si quisieran entrar en ese mercado.
Tendrían que evaluar entrevistas con padres locales
que quisieran un grupo de cuidadores de niños.
¿Vale la pena?
¿Deberían mirar otros sectores?
¿Deberían mudarse a otra parte del país
donde faltaran cuidadores de niños?
Este tipo de datos puede tornarse una rutina.
Los inversores pueden usar estos datos.
Y si hay una falta de cuidadores de niños en una parte del país
y nadie puede pagar la investigación de antecedentes y la capacitación,
puede pagarla un inversor
y el sistema devolverle pequeñas sumas por el aumento de ingresos de los individuos
durante quizá los siguientes dos años.
Este es un mundo de capitalismo atomizado.
Es el comercio pequeño, de las personas comunes,
pero muy bien informado, seguro, conveniente, económico e inmediato.
Algunas investigaciones sugieren que podría generar
nueva actividad económica por unos 100 millones de libras al día
en un país del tamaño del Reino Unido.
¿Les suena improbable?
Eso decía mucha gente de las transacciones automáticas
en los intercambios financieros hace 20 años.
No subestimen el poder de transformación
de los mercados verdaderamente modernos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)